we are talking about finite automata
last time and we had a look at
deterministic finite automata what are
these good for I mean they are sort of
fun to play this right but some people
that really I mean they cannot do any
sort of Theory without seeing the
Practical applications so let's say a
few words about this when you write a
compiler or any sort of programming
language there are some components like
which are sort of lexical which we need
lexical analysis for like what is what
is a what is an identifier what's a
number what's a comment and so on this
is a low level structure and this is
done via a regular Expressions finite
automata and so on so that's one of the
things they're good for yeah
um another thing is actually a regular
Expressions which are we will see
related to automata We Will We haven't
seen this yet they are useful to
describe patterns in text if you want to
write something like text processing
well if you want to write an editor
script yeah to do something using
regular expressions and they are
translated into into automata
practical yeah
so so another one is um protocols uh
communication protocols they're often
described by finite automata it's it's a
it's a good thing and then finite
automata sort of the entry The Rock So
to say to to so form a description of of
computation which which do playable in
theory as well as in applications
[Laughter]
okay yes so today as the last time we
talked about deterministic finite
automata
and um I I I I do a few and we played
with them uh so I mean this is under so
other video and you don't have to go
through this again but I wanted to do it
today is is another thing it's
non-deterministic finite automata and
what are they
we'll see they look very similar to the
DFAS but they're basically magic
machines whereas for a DFA you always
are in a state and then you send some
input you go to a different state for
the nfas you you there is maybe a choice
you maybe could go there or maybe here
or you may be going nowhere yeah
and and the magic is that an NFA it will
always make the right choice yeah if
there is a way that they could accept
the word it will make this Choice yeah
so they're really magic machines right
so we're going I mean if you get them
right
no no I mean yeah the magic okay yeah
that but they're matching and always
guessing right when they run right so so
this is in general actually the case
with non-deterministic automata I mean
there are other kinds of non-deteristic
automata like pushed on automata or
Turing machines they can be all
non-deterministic and they're always the
idea is they always do the right the
right choices it's a bit magic right
and you may ask what what are they good
for again yeah because the DFA is
clearly we can implement we can run but
the NFA is there seem to be a bit there
was a non-ded Mystic automata seemed to
be a bit sort of fancy in like you have
to have enough magic to be able to to
run them yeah the point is that they're
actually first of all in the case of the
nfas we will see we can translate them
into DFA that's not always possible for
other automatons not always possible but
in this case we can actually translate
them and the non-deterministic automaton
there it sort of in between the most of
abstract description of languages yeah
into actually implementation so they're
like a a thing in between so for example
when we look at regular Expressions we
can translate them first into
non-domestic finite automata and then
next step into DFAS but they're sort of
in between so they're useful as in
between us yeah so this example so we're
looking at at a language of words over
some alphabet so the alphabet is this
time is zero one so if you're looking at
sequences of zero one and the language
I'm going to uh just describe as a
language so that the penultimate symbol
of of the verge of the string is one
okay let's play the game that's that
that save as a shown as a good
alternative I've been practicing okay
very good what about
one zero is it in the language yes okay
what about one zero zero no no okay very
good
um what about
uh zero one zero yes very good
and what about one
oh no no it's not
exactly okay very good you I think I can
hire you as an automaton or something
you know okay so let's build okay how do
I do this fold the door
[Applause]
okay so let's build the automaton
so as we have seen already the automaton
they have little squiggles which are
states well it's not I I call the state
zero and I say it's my starting state so
I put an arrow in and now I say no no I
see a zero or one
I stay in the state
okay
but now if I see a run
I get sort of excited
because maybe
I'm going to win and then
I have another state whatever comes here
I go into this state
and this is my final state
okay so that's um that's an NFA
and
um
why is an NFA
um okay so first of all we have when we
Interstate 0 and we see a one we could
go here or we could go here right so
that's a bit weird all right and then
when we see a one okay with zero one we
go here but then what happens here what
happens if we see anything we there's no
no transition so it's not a DFA yeah for
two reasons so one reason in this case
we have got two options
and in this case we have no options but
let's see whether we can we can run this
automaton and you need a bit of
investment to play with nfas yeah so how
does this work so I'm I'm simulating an
NFA by putting coins on the states
remember that the DFA said it was my
finger but here it gets a bit more
complicated so let's say we want to do
one zero see what happens so one zero we
are here so we put a coin on the initial
state or actually an NFA can have
several initial States so we have to put
all the coins and all the initial States
this one is only one okay and now you
see we see a one so so this one goes
here but it also goes here so we are
like in two states now right we are in
state zero and state one at the same
time
like a superposition yes Phantom right
and now okay we have we have to add this
and now we read the zero so what happens
is uh
zero
and zero and we are finished and we have
a coin in the final state
so hence it's accepted okay let me do
one one one okay which I didn't ask
previously but I just accustomed to me
that's a good example okay we start with
this coin
then we have a one
so
let me go here
right
and now we have another one
so so
yeah if this coin stays here this coin
goes here and this coin goes here right
so we are finished and we have a coin in
the final state so it's accepted no
surprises so do a negative one what
about one zero zero one zero zero okay
so you start the corner one
so now we read the one
so we go here
now we read the zero
zero
and now we really noticeable this coin
has nowhere to go so we lose it it's
really a game of money you can lose
money you can win money but you can lose
stays where it is and we have no coin on
the final state so it's not accepted so
this is the final automaton and that's
where we run them right with coins but
the idea is that the current
self-represent all the states we could
be in now we can translate an NFA into a
DFA okay so here's the idea is that we
have a a DFA where the states are sets
of States so for example what we start
with is the state which has only the set
zero so now if you have a coin in state
zero what we do is we Define a DFA which
tracks the configuration of coins
basically yeah
so if we hit in state zero and we we see
a zero
then we still have just one coin and
zero so that's
this one here
or if you see a one then we obviously
have two coins so we have coin in zero
and one so we go zero one
okay so now let's say we're in zero one
what happens if we see a zero
what happens if you see a zero we stay
here and we go here so we are after zero
we are
in zero two
but let's dig in if you're in zero one
and we see a one
zero and if you see a one then this
go here but because we have a loop here
we go into 0 1 2 so if n zero one and we
see a one
and 0 1 2.
you're not finished we have to to get
transitions for these as well so what
that's again we're on zero two
and we see a zero what happens if you
see a zero this one is lost
but this one stays where it is so we are
back
to the state where we only have a coin
in zero
and what happens if you see a one so
let's get let's reset we have zero two
we see a one
then this coin disappears and here we
have two coins
right so that that means if you see one
I hope I didn't make a mistake here okay
so here we have zero one so we have to
see if we have three coins 012
and we see a zero what's happening this
this is here this is lost
so we are zero two
so if you see Zero you go to zero two
okay now what happens if here zero one
two
and we have a one we lose this one and
this all
okay so we have to mark initial state so
the state where we put the tokens and
the coins or the initial States is this
one
and and then
we have to mark the final States so
final states are any state which
contains a two where there's at least a
token a token a coin
on the two and this is in DFA right
because we have one initial State and we
have always exactly we know all what's
happening because we know what happens
to the coins
and this is a famous construct it's
called the power automaton
and it shows I mean hopefully the idea
is clear that we can translate any NFA
into a DFA into DFAS are easy to run
okay now why is this called Power
automaton because the states here are
sets of states so it's a power set and
in this case it's quite harmless we
start with three states we have four
states
but in in general it could be an
exponential blow up because with three
states we actually have eight possible
States two to the three because there
are eight possible subsets
and there are lots of states which are
not reachable which you don't have to
don't have to draw so another four
states which you don't have to draw
because it can never be reached but in
principle you can have automaton which
grew up like this so it's doable but not
always practical yeah exactly it's not
feasible
okay should we go to do some python
hackery let's do it yeah okay so here we
have the code from last time which was a
code for DFAS so we had a an init
function uh printing function and a run
function if you have some examples
okay I'm going to do the the NF is in
the same file because there's going to
be some interaction between the two
right you want to translate NF is to DFA
is actually also Divas to nfas which
seems should be easy but still we have
to do a bit of work okay so we define a
class NFA
is it that certain problems are only
able to be done within NFA to start with
and then you translate it or it's
certainly much easier so if you for
example you see I want to recognize a
fixed string yeah
then to do this to to constructed and
DFA can be non-trivial because I mean if
all the possible yeah yeah so it's much
easier to to construct the NFA and
principles you can translate it yeah
especially as I say if you come from
regular expressions
uh then it's quite straightforward to
construct for every regular expression
in the NFA
and then to the DFA but it's not so
obvious how to construct directly a DFA
and in terms of running this
computationally not on a piece of paper
with coins yes we're going to look at
that yeah yeah so we look at it is it
easier for the computer to do the DFI
sure yeah much easier yeah okay exactly
actually DFA has got a
linear complexity whereas for an NFA
it's first of all not clear I mean it
turns out after translation it's it's
also linear but okay the inner method
for the DFA is very similar the
difference is that for the initial State
we don't have not one unless you state
which we have a set of initial States
and the transition function Delta now
becomes the transition relation because
we don't know we don't always have
function given the state and given an
input we don't have one next state but
we have a set of next States and this
represents the relation right okay let
me just continue a bit the printing
function is called easy so nothing
exciting but let me first do my example
automaton okay so I call it n0 so what
we have to say we have to give the set
of States zero one two
set of symbols which is 0 and 1. and now
we give this transitional relation and
that's a bit more interesting than
before
so we assign
to any combination every combination of
uh of of a state and an input a set of
states
so here for example the set of State
if if you're in in zero and we see a one
then we could be in zero and one
then we can only be in two and if we
have one and one we can only be in two
so first of all we haven't really
described what happens for every
combination so this is implicitly for
the combinations we haven't covered it's
the empty set
and okay then we have here a set of
initial states which is just zero and
the set of final state which is two
okay
so what we now have to do is to define
the Run function for nfas and that's a
bit more involved than for DFAS we have
to define a run function this was very
easy in the case for the for the finite
automata with just a little while loop
going through the symbols and just use
the data function to compute the next
state but here okay we have to compute
the set of States at each step
and there's also the problems that
sometimes we haven't defined uh the the
answer and then it should be the empty
set
okay so what I'm doing here is I I have
a function called do Delta which
constructs the the set of the the states
looking up in this relation but if there
is no set then it Returns the empty set
okay and the Run function what it's
doing it it starts with the set p as a
current set of coins it's a set which is
in the initial State and then we have
this while loop as before
but we have to compute the the set of
new coins and what we do is we go
through all the states which are in P in
the moment apply this Delta function and
gets a new state and we take the union
of all these so we take the union of all
these possibilities
and in the end we set P to be this this
new state and when we have processed the
whole world we say the intersection of p
and the final State shouldn't be empty
okay so let's type to to run this we
have here this Autumn 10 and 0. so n0
don't run what was our first example one
zero
which is yes
and now we do one zero zero
and it is no
and what else all we want to do this
string which is just a one
which is also false okay
test cases
now we have these two classes NFA and
DFA it's first of all every every DFA
should be an NFA so how can we translate
a DFA into an NFA
so I'm going to write a conversion
method for DFAS called
nfas
to construct an in an NFA I have to
construct this new Delta function
and basically it returns a Singleton set
for for any transition in in the in the
Delta function
of the of cells the DFA
and it also constructs the Singleton set
here okay for the for the initial States
because there's only one so this
translation is pretty easy so this using
this function we can translate every DFA
to an NFA by just turning all these
single States into into Singletons and
that's just how it looks like in Python
but I'm going
to leave the the other translation the
power automation translation
I'm leaving this as an exercise but I
can provide the answer so here the idea
is if we have an NFA we want to
construct a corresponding DFA and there
we have to do this power automated
construction which I've just described
by example
so as I say that's left as an exercise
to the reader but I can provide the
answer if you get stuck
and now let's try this one
a
B
a bad State it's like kind of
engineering type things this one is
getting creating removing providing
criticizing so like for some reason
these types of words